Hello大家好,欢迎来到iMinephone台湾频道
过去是要掌握图像编辑等技术才能成为设计师
但随着人工智能的发展
AI文字生成图片已经非常常见
你只需要输入一句指定就能产生大量的作品
既能节省时间又能解决人力技术不足的问题
不管你想制作社群图片或是网站内容
今天的影片都会是你不如错过的使用干货
我们是用了市面上多款AI自动生成图片工具
选出了其中最好用的一款工具
推荐给你
我们要为你推荐的
就是iMaphone Checkout
这款全方位的AI助理
其他杂的GPT4
可以在几秒钟内
生成各种类型的图像
还有作文
长头诗
小说
故事
工作汇报
邮件
自卷等
软体提供的PC版本
和App版本
如果想免安装
直接使用的话
还支援网页版本
在线使用
如果你想使用App版本
可以点击说明栏中的连接
下载并安装iMaphone Checkout点选主节面下方的绘画功能选择想要创作的作品类型输入画面描述选择生成的图片风格
比例点击下一步
来图片生成完毕
即可得到想要的AI自动生成图片
如果你想免安装使用的话
同样可以点击说明栏中的连接
前往ChatArt的官网进行使用
点击线上使用前往网页在线版本
选择左侧的
人工智慧绘画板块
根据需求
点选图片类别
以继续
点选图像风格
并且描述图片场景
按设定影像比例
确认无误后
点击产生即可
如果不满意生成的图片
可以再次点击产生
生成一张新的图片
好啦
今天的影片就到这里咯
最后别忘记订阅我们的频道
我会随时分享
更多AI文字生成图片
有問題的話也可以在留言區我交流哦
掰掰